this is the building and key where
Ukraine stores precious meteorological
data from Antarctica
a rocket struck the intersection in
October
as you can see the cracks on the wall
and you can see there's a broken ceiling
uh there's a Russian missile of the Heat
hit the road nearby and the windows were
completely destroyed despite the damage
the polar scientists continue to work 15
000 kilometers away their colleagues are
doing research at the vanatsky station
in Antarctica to collect data to study
climate change all right
was fighting at the front line when he
was sent to lead the station even this
far from home the war feels very near
just today I received information from
my the brother here in war and mouth is
hospital and it's very difficult to not
to think about about this about my
friends about my
relatives
but we must to walk here many of his
colleagues stayed behind to fight Igor
actor mango has a doctorate in
meteorology and has just returned from
the front line
we weren't given a choice if everyone
doesn't go to fight maybe there won't be
any signs left or if there is anything
left it will be some kind of Russian
science I consider this a war of values
meteorologists can rest for six days
before he'll need to go back to his
troops these scientists are fighting on
two fronts continuing their battle
against climate change in the Antarctic
but also fighting Russians on the front
line here and while there are enemies
here both Russia and Ukraine are part of
the Antarctic treaty and are meant to
work together
signed in 1959 it designates the
Antarctic a demilitarized zone the war
is now causing cracks in The Pact and
Russia was saying that we are trying to
politicize the process and Antarctica is
a continent of priests peace and we
bring in vase and I was like no it's not
we bring invar to Antarctica it's you
who is kosenvar these scientists say
they will never be able to work with
their Russian colleagues again and hope
they'll still be able to collect data on
global warming as most of their budget
has been redirected to the war step fast
and Al Jazeera Keith
foreign